jarre déviation obligatoire chevallier
laspalès
c'est au théâtre comédien paris besançon
strasbourg
voilà mais ensuite à marigny donc alors
il ya aussi un coffret
en
ferrer se passe bien entre vous l'a très
bien
un cinquième patte inquiète tu préfères
pas attendre que soit opérée non alors
philippe chevallier bonsoir dont vous
êtes né le 11 janvier 1956 à redon des
licenciés en droit célibataire et vous
avez une passion c'est la photo voilà un
et régis laspalès vous vous êtes né le
25 février 1957 à paris diplômée des
beaux-arts célibataire aussi d'être
célibataire tous les deux et vous avez
une passion ce sont les voitures
anciennes voilà vous êtes rencontrés au
cours simon
un jour au cours simon régis vous avouer
à philippe que vous vous lever la nuit
pour boire
cela fait flasher parce que je venais
que je buvais un peu de vin ouais
l'année oui mais en fait je mettais du
vin dans l'eau 1
mais pour ce soit plus agréable
il a trouvé ça bien un dc10 faut que je
travaille avec ce type là effectivement
je suis est très sympathique
ouais alors vous avez une vraie passion
pour la photo à photographier des femmes
en collant des jambes de femmes et des
fesses de valeur que vous êtes obsédés
des chattes aussi de tout ce qui est de
tous qui galbent le sexe de la femme les
jambes les oui bien sûr
rien que pour vous une fois qu'une femme
est emballé dans le monde uni longue
soit un collant set ça devient comme une
sculpture de mayol oui un peu c'est ça à
cause du côté complètement lisse ouais
et puis de cette chose qui donne cette
couleur un peu bronze dans laquelle elle
se passe que ça brille dans laquelle
elle se moulent elle se coule ses
chagrins vers vers le sahara est cinglé
et excite lui la très belle photo
pourquoi pas 36 mais alors comment es tu
vas faire ce que tu veux à la
photographie en collant
alors ça j'ai pas fait on a ici le
moment de commencer ma mandat voilà
bientôt un voyage ça va te plaire tueur
avant qu'elle se fasse opérer bien sûr
alors on va faire ça on va on va prendre
rendez vous auprès du maître régis vous
aimez les voitures anciennes
supplications gager remise en jeu me
l'automobile en général et le sport
automobile
1 mais le galbe des vieilles
carrosseries ça vous excite ceni sait
ces deux vieux pervers qui voudra fils
et filles dans des collants et l'autre
qui aime bien les carrosseries des
arrondis comme j'aime bien les châssis
ouais c'est vrai que la métaphore jeu
sadique
est-ce que vous avez déjà arraché les
pattes d'une mouche par exemple non mais
j'ai noyé des fourmis
est ce que vous aimez pincer le bout des
seins les filles le cas échéant
ouais et pourquoi pas régis pourquoi pas
est ce que vous aimez regarder des
vieilles dames tomber dans la rue vous
nous posez la question à tous les deux
ah là là et alors non non non non non
mais on enlève aux pommes
non non pas du tout savez ce que c'est
pour moi le comble de la perversion
comme ça physique
c'est quelqu'un qui s'amusait qui
trouvent ça drôle à retourner la
paupière à chaud je ne peux pas à l
annonce va pas me faire ils sont bien
non vous festif nous mais c'est charmant
qu'elle s'enfonce du barbu non sérieux
j'ai bien drôle il est chaud bouillant
voilà ce règne une espèce
bien sûr mieux soir au théâtre comédia
riina le stress mois consulte les êtres
humains
et puis aussi des insuccès castelli
blatter
tous les ans kate
et